about this fugitive down in Texas
apparently he's running around in this
pickup truck I want to see if it's a
white Bronco Texas Paul
good morning good morning how are you I
am wonderful I'm saying [ __ ] this Texas
Paul segment and you keep on that rant
that is the best damn rent I've heard in
decades I'm telling you brother I am
we'll cut that son of a [ __ ] up and
we'll make some clips out of it how's
that so do it do it I'm telling you that
was on the money on the money you nailed
it I mean point after point after Point
democracy we don't wait for Beto or
anybody else or Beto or Biden or anybody
else we are the democracy and it's time
we start talking some [ __ ] and telling
people the way it is it is I mean and
that's what I'm I'm with you man I tell
my people all the time hey I may talk
[ __ ] but you need to talk [ __ ] because
you're absolutely right if there's one
[ __ ] Nazi at that table and 10 people
sitting with them there's 11 goddamn
Nazis at that table you damn right
you're damn right and you know I know I
know some people get you know as shy
about this because they got family
members and stuff well shame the [ __ ]
out of them it's time it's time these
Americans wake up and change their
[ __ ] minds and realize what they have
done what they've done the cat they have
let out of the bag and it's their
responsibility to put it back in but
it's our responsibility to tell them put
that [ __ ] back in the bag go crawl back
underneath the [ __ ] rock it's enough
of this nonsense when you have you
watched this Roger Stone video yeah not
yet I'm dying to see a delusion well I'm
gonna show it today I'm gonna show it
today but the reason why I wanted you
um
of course you're on every Tuesday but I
couldn't wait to talk to you about this
what in the actual [ __ ] is going on with
this fugitive down there in Texas you
know what I'm talking about
yeah Ken Paxton yeah oh is he the
sitting attorney general this is
ridiculous this is crazy yeah he's the
attorney general and uh see the problem
is it's it's deeper than just I mean
it's hilarious to laugh at it really is
but it's much deeper than that what you
got going on right now is they
overturned Roe v Wade and they found out
that they [ __ ] the bit
so everybody's expunging their their
bios you know overturning the road
they're pro-choice now right they're
pro-choice yeah all of a sudden yeah all
of a sudden they don't want to talk
about it well down here in Texas because
Republicans can't govern they made a
complete [ __ ] show of our loss we had
pre-love pre-roll laws on the book okay
so when Roe was over to overturned those
laws came back into effect well then
they wrote other laws that conflict with
those existing laws
they're identical enough that they don't
supersede the law
but they the the punishments are
different like uh the for supporting uh
uh funding somebody getting an abortion
in the state of Texas carries uh under
the new laws five to life under the Old
Law two to five
so you have groups that actually do this
for people because you know the big
problem is they talk about late term
abortions or after 16 weeks there's a
reason they do that because a lot of
poor people
have to get the funds together to be
able to afford an abortion they have to
get Transportation time away from jobs
this hadn't the other that takes times
well there are groups that actually help
them that that fund them so that they
can get this done
those groups have been suing Ken Paxton
saying look these laws are willy-nilly
their mishmash none of them are clear we
need guidance from you the head law
enforcement officer in the state what is
the law and Ken Paxton doesn't want to
talk about abortion at all right now I
mean he wants to say nothing about it
so
I mean they they had to subpoena him
he wouldn't do it willingly they had to
subpoena him it seems like a pattern
with these [ __ ] traitors I mean yeah
I'm just saying there's nothing to hide
in your opinion and you believe in your
your opinion and you think that your
political stance is something you'd
stand behind you think [ __ ] get
in front of a microphone and say it yeah
well you'd think but he doesn't want to
stand in front of a microphone right now
and say yes if you help someone get an
abortion I'm going to prosecute you and
send you to jail possibly for life he
doesn't want to say that so he's been
hiding he's been hiding from every
camera in the world which is unlike Ken
walleye Paxton that guy usually loves
being in front of him yeah
and so he's hiding up in his house and
process server shows up at his house
knocks on the door talks to his wife
wife says well Ken's busy this that and
the other he's going to be tied up for a
long time he says no problem I'm a
process server I'll wait
all right and the guy walking he gets
paid he gets paid to hand him the papers
right so the guy walks back to his car
gets off their property walks back to
his car sits in his car I guess they
thought they waited long enough that the
guy left or something
Ken Paxton goes to walk out to his
pickup truck process over gets out of
his car walks up his driveway announces
who he is what he's got Ken Paxton turns
around and runs as fast as that fat ass
can run
all the way back into his house and
slams the door
she stays
he stays for about another hour right so
the guy goes back sits out in his car
all of a sudden an SUV pulls up
and then
Paxton's wife comes out and gets in
their pickup truck
opens the opens the the door behind her
it's a crew cab pickup truck opens the
door behind her well that's typical
behavior when you're gonna pull away
yeah and how run outruns Ken Paxton from
his garage as fast as he can run and
dives into his pickup truck slams the
door process server walks up to the
truck drops the papers and says you are
served
goes back and reports this whole
incident to the judge because you know
what people don't understand is just
because you don't accept the papers from
the process over doesn't mean they
haven't served you right if they've
notified you and even if even if they
can never catch you at your home
they can go back to the judge and say
hey I couldn't catch the guy at home and
tape it to your door and you're served
right so all of this was just stupidity
on Ken Paxton's part but it just shows
how terrified he knows this because he's
an attorney general for crying out loud
well he should know it and if he doesn't
know it he doesn't need to be an
attorney general of anything
yeah and that you could tell their whole
plan was to try to get away before the
guy could say you're served
you know and he did he walked right up
to the truck looked Ken Paxton right in
the eye told him you're served and
dropped the paperwork on the ground
and left and it was done done deal but I
mean the guy was just literally on the
run I mean he just anything he could do
to try to keep from getting served
because they do not want to talk about
Roe v Wade right now they would rather
get take a square kick in the nuts than
talk about Roe v Wade right hey I'm not
exactly against that I'm not exactly
against that you know I don't promote uh
physical violence but if they would
rather you know if we're playing Would
You Rather game you ever played that
game when you're a kid would you rather
if we're playing the Would You Rather
game I mean hell that seems like a good
would you rather would you rather talk
about your stance on abortion or take a
swift kick in the nuts I mean you know
it's just a game you play it's just a
game yeah all right it was hilarious
though do you think do you think though
that this has an effect on on the
electorate and the election in Texas
just a visual of this that he won't get
served
well here's the thing right now Abbott
has been just blitzing the Airways with
this operation Lone Star
and the whole Roe v Wade thing because
they're expunging all of their websites
everything is actually gotten a little
quiet here in Texas
so Abbott has actually picked up a few
points in the polls but that's going
away because if you don't mind me
jumping off topic for a minute yeah go
ahead operation Lone Star as of today is
blowing up in Abbott's face
turns out see they've been fighting
requests for data on operation Lone Star
for from every journalist everywhere and
now it's starting to come out
what Abbott's been doing down here he
spent four billion dollars so far going
on five billion now with a B with a b b
billion dollars okay he activated the
National Guard sent them down to if
you've never been to South Texas that's
the Sonoran Desert okay sent them down
into the middle of a desert in the
middle of summer
five died
and and it it cost a [ __ ] ton of money
to do this okay then he took law
enforcement agents and shipped them from
one County
to counties on On the Border
and turned around and said man we're
making fentanyl arrests we're making
we're we're arresting people for for
crossing the border we're Prosecuting
them and this that and the other Well
turns out no they're not Joe Biden is
you know they try to say that the border
is open well one of the biggest [ __ ]
we Democrats have is Biden never
repealed title 42 from Trump right
so they are they are sending people that
back without trial because of the
coveted restrictions
left and right that's one of our biggest
complaints so no the border is not open
second point that the border is not open
it comes out all these fentanyl requests
he's been uh arrests he's been claiming
have been happening at the border
crossings Tony who controls the border
crossing you mean you mean the the
actual Gates the actual Gates right now
not over a fence or under a fence or
through a broken fence because if Trump
made it not not over the river not any
of that you're saying you're saying that
they're coming through the legal path
the legal gate that you're supposed to
come through you're saying that's where
it's coming through that's where they're
arresting them and yeah
I think DHS is responsible
um and border security is responsible
the feds are responsible for those
they're making that's right none of this
has to do with the billions of dollars
that Abbott is spending the federal
government the the the
border patrol agents that are out there
are making the arrests for uh people
that are actually Crossing illegally
the most people that are coming across
are coming across through the through
the gates saying I want to Asylum from
the Nicholas Maduro
regime down in Venezuela that's just
brutally murderous
Communists which is even another it's
another damned dichotomy that we I can't
even understand why Republicans you
would think they would take advantage of
that but they're they clearly are more
hell-bent on on
dehumanizing brown people than they are
actually sticking to their what they
call their principles exactly exactly
and they're trying to say is all cartels
and this is the huge one this is the
this is the where Abbott gets the pie in
the face think about that number 4
billion going on five billion dollars
the fentanyl require arrests are being
done by federal agents
at the bridges at the portals oh at at
the ports where they're coming through
is where the federal agents are making
these arrests and Abbott's claiming them
as his own well the Chariot on the top
of the [ __ ] cake
85 percent of the fentanyl requests we
found out today the request I keep
saying requests 85 percent of the
fentanyl arrests we found out today
were American citizens
you mean the mules are actually
Americans that can cross in legal ports
and legal Crossings and that's the ones
that are going and getting the Fentanyl
and bringing it back are you telling me
that they're trying to work this
fentanyl in the trunk of a car behind
the seat like like they like they always
have this is again this is par for the
course but hey I want to show you a clip
here I got a clip here this is uh Fox
news this morning you know you said that
your attorney general Ken Paxton
speaking of the Border in this operation
Lone Star and then you rope in Ken
Paxton here Ken Paxton did get in front
of a camera he's willing to appear on
Fox News he's not a willing to appear on
each thing else the funny part is
she doesn't really ask him she doesn't
really ask him about how he ran from the
law but let's let's watch a bit of this
glute let me see if I can get the volume
right
I'm gonna tell the audience why we're I
am just in the volume here we're going
to be changing our volume situation
hopefully the this afternoon or tomorrow
so our volume problems are gonna start
to start to go away I have a feeling but
let's listen to this video we have
sovereignty as a nation
I suppose we should we do right but I
don't know anymore
Ken Paxton Attorney General of Texas
Mark brnovich Attorney General of
Arizona gentlemen you know what it takes
to get border patrol agents to talk with
you openly about this they want to serve
their government but you know who
they're most worried about the people of
this country A.G Paxton I'm going to
start with you is Texas doing the work
the governing on this issue that the
federal government is not doing
we're certainly trying I mean we have to
deal with natural disasters that but
with a natural disaster like a hurricane
it goes away this is a planned Disaster
by the Biden Administration that is
hurting my state that's hurting Mark's
State that's hurting the entire country
and as you as you talk to these
borderies still in place I've been on
the border I've been on Horseback I've
been in boats I've been into helicopters
he's also been in his pickup truck or in
and away from uh subpoenas being served
to him I'm not going to Blade the rest
of this garbage again she goes on she
never [ __ ] asks him the real question
everyone really wants to know about
their supposed top law enforcement
officer in the state who won't be
legally sir or try to be get out of
being legally served with the subpoena
because he won't lawfully [ __ ] appear
where he's supposed to appear and they
have to use the law to get him to appear
and you know and and just more of the
same and Tony what he says that this is
a naturally this is a man-made created
design faster
how title 42 is still in place the only
thing the Biden Administration did
differently was they were not cruel with
the kids they make sure kids stay with
their families or if it's a kid that
gets caught that comes across alone or
or if it's kid that comes across with
can with somebody that's a a felon or
that we arrest
that kid is reunited with their family
wait you're telling me you're telling
difference you're telling me there's
some Humanity there is that what you're
telling me yeah and that's the thing
they're saying this is a man-made crisis
like Biden did something different he's
doing exactly what Trump did that's the
Democrats biggest [ __ ] right is that
Biden is doing exactly what Trump did
title 42 is still in place
the only difference is they aren't being
cruel to kids and I guess that's what
Paxton is saying when it's a man-made
thing is that because we aren't throwing
kids in [ __ ] cages like animals that
this is suddenly you know an open border
which is the other [ __ ] the other
difference too from what I understand
about the title 42 is the bind
Administration is working with the
Mexican Government on this title 42
whereas the Trump Administration was not
working with them they were just
dropping them off [ __ ] them just let
them do whatever the hell they want so
there's a little what did we get out of
that and what did we get out of that
Biden actually got Mexico to Pony up a
billion and a half dollars to help with
this problem so that we weren't just
dumping people right inhumanely back
across the border to nothing well
because it was causing a problem in
Mexico having all these folks having all
these folks being coyote by us back
across the border and just dumping them
and why what essentially became camps
right because they had no other place to
go which was causing problems on the
other side of the border so now that we
have an Administration that's willing to
work with the administration in Mexico
and try to help solve this Refugee
problem because that's really what we
have here we have we have migrants
fleeing from governments and we have
them trying to seek Asylum and refuge to
the majority of the extent that's why
that's why a lot of them are staying
here is because and they couldn't stay
here if they weren't legally seeking
Asylum that's the title 42 they're
sending the people back across that
aren't legally entitled to Refugee
status and and to seek legally seek
Asylum and let me put a bow on this Tony
that just tells you how [ __ ] awful
this is
in the state of Texas we by law have to
have a balanced budget right
where the [ __ ] do you think four and a
half to five billion dollars is going to
come from well I'm sure I'm sure I'm
sure your energy grid and your highways
will pay for it yourself
our roads our schools it's going to come
from our agricultural supports it's
going to come from our law enforcement
they're going to end up laying off law
enforcement over this
and he's talking about being the Law and
Order governor
you know I mean they are literally
pardon the expression but fist [ __ ]
our next budget so when Beto takes over
this is the first crisis that hits his
desk it's where the hell do I get five
billion dollars from
to cover
[ __ ] Abbott's re-election campaign
because that's all operation Lone Star
is he should be sued this should be a
class action lawsuit they are producing
nothing this is not a genuine law
enforcement operation the the guard has
no authority to arrest
them being there is just Visual and it
cost a shitload of money for that visual
um
exactly exactly we're literally
literally careening towards five billion
dollars with a B headline headline
headline headline headline
five billion dollars with a B to take
credit for what the [ __ ] Biden
Administration is doing right well you
know
um I I would say the number one question
if I were in Texas and I would say to
lean into democracy and engage the
number one question I'd say for people
to ask is who do you want in charge of
fixing this five billion dollar problem
that the Republicans of Greg Abbott have
created do you want Greg Abbott to help
fix that problem or do you want someone
who's pragmatic who gives a [ __ ] about
Texas is gonna do it it's not gonna be
pretty but he's going to do it try to do
it the best way he can is better that's
your choice here that's your choice you
got the choice whether you want the
[ __ ] idiot who's caused this problem
who spent this Texas money which
shouldn't be spent on a political stunt
just like shipping migrants all across
the country when they shouldn't be
spending money on that either they
should be spending money on trying to
help these people seek Asylum and refuge
and get them get them acclimated into
our society and part of our economy for
crying out loud we need the [ __ ]
labor we need we need the human means we
need them here in this country to keep
our economy going and another reason no
kin walleye Paxton doesn't want to be
put in front of a camera is he's going
to get asked the question
are you using coveted relief funds
in this anti-abortion push and the
answer is yes
and that they're using it in operation
Lone Star did you know they emptied out
the an entire prison here in the state
of Texas took felons moved them to
for-profit prisons
and emptied out a prison down in Three
Rivers Texas it's called the Briscoe
unit and they're taking you know the
federal government
once they had arrest somebody
they hand them over to the state of
Texas but they pay the state of Texas
for that right it's a kind of houses for
the detainment right so he emptied out
the Briscoe unit he is putting
Asylum Seekers people waiting for
adjudication waiting to be sent back
in a federal high security I mean pardon
me a state high security prison that's
supposed to be housed housing the worst
of our felons
and he's telling nobody where he shipped
these people off to over a thousand of
our worst felons
I mean it sounds like human trafficking
it sounds on brand for these Republicans
to be quite honest with you
in did he cut him loose I mean I don't
know the the the for-profit prisons
won't tell us if they got them
you know because that looks bad that
that they're pumping people into the
for-profit prisons you know so they're
not going to talk to us about that you
know you can't get a [ __ ] straight
answer out of these people because
they're terrified because everything
they're doing looks like [ __ ] well it
looks criminal too I mean I know I know
there's a Sheriff
um San Antonio looking into Ron DeSantis
and his crimes that he's possibly
committed in Texas which is a weird
sentence to even say because Ron
DeSantis is the governor of Florida and
you think that [ __ ] would be
more worried about his State being
battered by a hurricane and had paid
attention to this hurricane you know if
I was Joe Biden you know what I'd do
because they're going to send federal
funds and ironde DeSantis is going to be
on his knees ready to do fellatio to
give to pass out federal checks to his
constituents which a governor should be
able to do
to help protect their state it doesn't
matter what [ __ ] State you're in or
who the governor is or who your
constituents vote for their goddamn
Americans are in America we should we
should stand behind people when there's
a national disaster like a flood or a
goddamn hurricane
but Biden should say Biden should say
I'm going to make sure to help Ron
DeSantis I'm gonna make sure to help
Rhonda Santos help his people in Florida
but I just hope I just hope that he
doesn't steal every single dollar that I
send him for those people in Florida
because he's got a history and if you
want to make sure that the governor of
Florida doesn't steal the money the
federal dollars that we're going to send
to help prop Florida up and give them a
head start here after this hurricane
because we know there's going to be
damage it's just it's just a thing
that's going to happen we're gonna lose
money they're going to lose economy
they're gonna need some they're going to
need some relief what he should say is
vote in someone who won't steal the
Goddamn money
that's what he should say he should
politicize the ever loving [ __ ] out of
this point now I know Joe Biden's not
much of a politicizer but I'm going to I
am
I tell you I just went nuts I literally
just did a video on this man it'll be
coming out in a day or two I literally
just did a video on this it has footage
of a line of cars man you think they
were going to a Dolphins game you would
think they were going into a stadium man
this line is so freaking long of these
cars it's in Levee County Florida
they're going to a food bank right
they're going to a food bank and
DeSantis took and the and and the
Republicans in the legislature took 12
million dollars
sent a recruiter to Texas San Antonio
Texas
took people that were here legally
that were legally going through the
process of of getting Asylum
because they were escaping they were
Venezuelans escaping the Maduro murder
regime
and then put them on a plane lied to
them put them up in a hotel
made them sign releases that were
worthless because they were in half in
English and they knew they couldn't
speak English
then ship them up to Martha's Vineyard
as a big haha joke trying to trigger the
liberal trigger us liberals and and they
have no [ __ ] clue they didn't trigger
us we were so damn glad those people
weren't under Abbott's boot anymore
they're out there getting help with
their cases they're up there being you
know getting the hand up that they
should be you know as as My Brother's
Keeper they should be be being they
should be being treated but he took that
money
from Florida who's got people lined up
in food banks to send legal people to
[ __ ] Martha's Vineyard you would
think you would think Floridians would
have the wherewithal to uh and I think
they do I think that's the biggest fraud
that has been wrought on our country is
somehow this is a half half thing this
is not a half half thing
when when Joe Biden came out and called
Maga Republicans fascist he did not tell
half of the country they were fascist
because half the country doesn't buy
this Maga [ __ ] they just don't that
is such a [ __ ] fraud they don't buy
that nonsense that is such [ __ ]
they just don't I I can't [ __ ] I
can't tell you how much I think that's a
bunch of [ __ ] and I think if we just
if we all band together and we take our
government back and we do what we're
supposed to do which is democracy
and anyone who can vote votes check your
registration get anybody you can
register to vote make sure they check
the registration engage in your
democracy let them know what's at stake
and I believe it's an easy goddamn
decision just like in Texas the question
do you want Greg Abbott to try to fix
the budget problem that he created is
that who you want to fix it or do you
want someone who's got a half a [ __ ]
brain who's willing to sit down and tell
the honest truth to Texans and give it
to him straight that hey the last guy
[ __ ] this up and works gonna cost us
money but we gotta do it there ain't
nothing to do but the Constitution it's
the law but we're going to try our
damnedest we're going to try our best
and I'm going to try to create a plan to
get us out of it instead of burying Us
in another [ __ ] hole like Greg Abbott
would do so that's the question you
gotta have folks whether you're in Texas
or all around the country
Hey sir you gonna let these buffoons who
are spending our [ __ ] money on
[ __ ] political stunts and taking it
away from you that's the question you
gonna let them be in power you're gonna
let them keep doing it
speak the question we gotta ask speak it
brother speak it
so that I think is the the thing that um
we need to get through the skulls of
people in the next 40 days now we got a
hearing tomorrow that's gonna help uh
shed some light on some things
um that's going on in our country
um what what do you make because you're
gonna join us tomorrow Texas Paul as you
have uh for the coverage of the January
6th select hearing but we got day nine
coming up it's been a while since we've
had one of these hearings it's it's the
start of season two of treason Hunters
as I called it this morning
um what do you make of this hearing what
do you expect do you think this is going
to move the needle or do you think it's
been too long since the last one or do
you think that's by Design
no no I I I think part of it was letting
Benny Thompson get over coveted I think
part of it was the collection of
evidence that that this just Tony this
ballooned
I mean everything that they got into
everybody they talked to kept saying oh
by the way did you know this happened
also and they're like what what look get
the notebook start writing things down
and then well we need to subpoena this
and we need to I mean it just ballooned
and and and I think that's been the
delay between that and that they've been
cooperating with the doj on everything
that's happened so far
and mark my words what's coming down the
pike I have heard this I haven't
confirmed it what's coming down the pike
is you remember that video of trump
loading boxes
into his private jet yeah sure I
remember that that was two days after he
was notified
that the government wanted that back
right that was two days and that jet was
going to Bedminster you watch you watch
they are gonna raid every damn property
he has
and I don't I you know he better have a
lot of [ __ ] ketchup that's all I've
got to say well you better have a stock
in it well I'll tell you I'll tell you
the other the other um word this morning
is there's some reporting showing that
it's possible Department of Justice is
signaling to the Attorney General of New
York that hey those documents that you
wanted for your civil case that you
subpoenaed they're they're they're in
these [ __ ] they're they were in his
desk drawer hidden in in melania's
closet or wherever the hell he had him
in the pool house wherever he had him
look it is not surprising to me that
this guy is going to continue to commit
crime this is not surprising the only
thing that will surprise me is if he
actually if he was smart enough to evade
this that was what will surprise me Tony
Tony
what is so bad about those documents
being in those boxes
down in Mar-A-Lago is that Trump sat
under oath and said
I don't know [ __ ] about this this is the
company that runs it I don't know the
stuff you're looking for talk to Alan
weiselberg this is the company I don't
know [ __ ] about it so you're saying you
should have put the food
you lied under oath because you knew you
took those specific
documents tomorrow [ __ ] Lago well
because he thought he could take it
across the state line there's no way
they would find it that's why he's
pissed off that's why he keeps saying
they're my it's my [ __ ] and ain't got
nothing to do with the government
because it's got to do with other crime
in other states he always tells on
himself he always does it that's why I
believe the goddamn top secret uh the
classified information the human
intelligence that he that he stole from
us from our government has his goddamn
name on it it is intelligence that our
intelligence that our intelligence
agencies has collected on him
and that's why he keeps saying it's his
because it's got his stupid [ __ ] name
on it and I keep comparing him to Al
Capone yes Al Capone was a vicious
murderer he ran numbers rackets he ran
extortion rackets he you know broke the
Volstead Act and sold booze and every
other damn thing in the world they could
not nail him down for because everybody
was terrified of him they got him on tax
evasion they got him on the cover up
that's what he went to sing sing for and
the same thing will happen to Trump
trump just lied under oath
that he did not know a damn thing about
these documents and they were in his
goddamn desk drawer and in his safe he
he moved them to another state
he took them out of the companies he
took them out of the companies
uh storage and moved them to Mar-A-Lago
he lied under oath Tony he lied under
oath period there's no other way about
it no other way around it what's he
going to say uh um I I guess Eric did
that I mean who do you think he's going
to try to throw under the bus for that
nobody man he's done he's [ __ ] done
well that's why today's that's why it's
today's thumbnail
um presents that in the most obvious way
I can I can show he's [ __ ] he's
absolutely [ __ ] here he knows he's
[ __ ] that's why he's been freaking out
that's why he's been freaking out about
the FBI breaking into Mar-A-Lago and he
really thought that under under the
guise of being the former president and
and and using fear and stoking fear and
violence in the country and he had
Secret Service there as what he thought
would protect him not just privately not
just publicly but legally from law
enforcement coming in and seizing this
[ __ ] that's why he had it down there
it's because they're protecting that
house because he's there and and
unbeknownst to them I bet these federal
agencies Secret Service I bet they've
been wearing wires I bet they've been
informing because there they have an
oath and I don't give a [ __ ] if their
oath is to protect them their oath is to
protect our constitution as well
and let me leave you with a happy
thought yeah
if he gets convicted if mayor Garland
gets him he goes to Club Fit right
but when he lied under oath even though
it's a civil suit up in New York
that sends his ass to a place like
Rikers oh baby well I I will tell you I
can enjoy that state time you stupid fat
orange mango Mussolini [ __ ]
enjoy your state time well I I think
he's gonna get uh state and federal time
um here for a lot of different things
because he's committed a lot of crime
he's really and he he is committed to
keep criming he's not gonna stop I mean
this is this is a habit he can't break
apparently and uh Texas Paul as always I
always appreciate you joining us on
Tuesday and tomorrow we'll have you with
the coverage uh on Midas Touch network
of the January 6 day 9 hearing I'm super
excited to see this Roger Stone stuff uh
stick around in the green room if you
want to watch this video Roger Stone I'm
going to show a couple Clips here of
Roger Stone absolutely losing his ever
loving mind and admitting right out in
the open you got God did you did you
order a code red you goddamn right I did
that's exactly it is the code red moment
of Roger Stone uh it is a freak out
moment and it's it's months before the
election which is even more telling that
this was all premeditated they knew he
was gonna lose and they planned on
stealing it if he did lose that was the
plan the entire [ __ ] time and you'll
see that in this clip and tomorrow I
can't wait for you to join us on the
January 6 um select hearing but give us
one last Shameless plug because I know
you got a couple shows going over on
your YouTube channel so give us a
Shameless plug here
all right uh Wednesday night man we're
starting at 8 central we are it's me and
Tennessee Brando uh talking about
current events it's a great show it's
just 30 minutes it's short it's quick
it's fast it's sweet we hit it hard we
bring we're bringing in a great guest uh
a lot of people know her to Care Bear
she's got straight up documents on on
them trying to you know they're
constantly trying to rewrite fiction uh
about what happened in the past and
they're trying to reinvent Trump's
economy she's nailing them to the wall
with that she's she's good to go on that
and then Sunday there's always Sunday uh
coffee with Texas Paul where I talk
about kind of a wrap-up of the Week
events and what's been happening lately
I sure appreciate you all available on
my uh my YouTube channel can be found
through my link tree it's it's linked
tr.e slash Texas Paul
well thank you Texas Paul thanks for
joining us I look forward to tomorrow
when you join us for the coverage of the
January 6th select hearing and uh
everyone go follow Texas Paul's YouTube
channel and catch his Wednesday show and
the Sunday show and Tony I always got to
say it man I am here uh you know I am
here because I love being here I love
being with somebody which has as much
damn passion as I do about this you are
the best podcast
available right now period
you are setting the bar you are raising
the standards and damn it man I it's a
pleasure to be here every damn time you
and Gabe kill it just kill it every week
and it's it's my pleasure to be here
well yeah it's a good pleasure to have
us it's your our pleasure to have you is
what I mean
not just on Tuesdays anytime you need to
you can come on the show not just
Tuesdays of course you're welcome on
Tuesday together yeah I will take you up
on that I'm going to mute out I want to
see this video this that I haven't had a
chance to see you yet that's great
everyone stick around we're gonna come
back uh we should have Gabe Sanchez with
us on the other side of the break we're
gonna watch this Roger Stone video Texas
Paul thanks for joining us as always on
Tuesdays everyone stick around we'll be
right back right after this break